hey guys how's it going welcome back to
cooking with Justine I'm Justine and
today we're gonna be making banana bread
now one of you guys suggested that I
make this video and I actually think
it's a great idea because I'm super
obsessive about my bananas I only eat
bananas when they're like green and
perfectly yellow without any brown spots
so these bananas as you can see are
definitely not in Justine condition
could be eaten so let's turn these into
banana bread
I've already got my ingredients set up
before me let me see what we need to do
first in a mixing bowl mash the bananas
with a fork until smooth Oh No Oh No
we will put you in a blender like
there's a Mario Cart joke to be made
here but I'm not able to think of any
he's actually looked pretty good inside
so if I would have opened these up this
is I would have eaten these melted
butter how much melted butter do we need
we need a melt the butter don't worry
I'm on it
pour the batter into your prepared this
is actually really easy oh no no no no
no oh I think you're done I think you're
done your boiling boiling put you in the
Nana mixture mixing baking soda and salt
how much baking soda when do I put my
egg I'm just gonna put this all in here
like honestly like it just really even
matter at this point and no it doesn't
not what does it
everything doesn't even it just doesn't
it's fine it's fine
well fine baking soda I got baking soda
I got baking soda teaspoon of baking
soda a pinch of salt just a little pinch
pinch way more than a pinch one teaspoon
of vanilla extract all right looks good
way more than it should have been half
of sugar all right I think that was a
cup looks like a cup to me I think I'm
gonna mix this and then put the flour in
and Chloe started let's put you on get
in there oh this is fantastic
this is perfect I am so good at this the
back of this uh flower has a banana
bread recipe well our to beat you to it
buddy
so one I'm just gonna do this part
because I kind of want to take a bite of
it so I'm just this is the only thing
that we're gonna measure today
one and a half get in yeah do what I
want you to do it's working actually
amazing
I can't believe you can make anything on
freaking blender
the problem is nobody ever tried me this
is it this is apps this is it all right
time to put her in the pan I think this
is gonna be like perfectly fine but I'm
not sure not sure you know get it out
there you know what works better than
spatula your hand forget your oven to
350 degrees and then put it in here and
let me just tell you what you guys have
to bake this for an hour an hour and 10
minutes or until it's done how am I
supposed to know when it's done I don't
know these are questions that are
supposedly told to me on the internet
and you go little guy
see you on the other side friend see you
in an hour
all right I think the banana bread is
ready to be taken out of the oven I'm
not a hundred percent sure but let's uh
let's see let's take a peek oh geez how
the little cakes get in there oh I don't
know magic happens
oh that looks good well it's actually
really good okay let's let your cool
trough in it shall we
look at you building a real cake oh I
just I just flopped out like a friggin
fish okay
this looks good holy crap Jenna look at
this do you like banana bread Lisa this
looks good right let's give him a little
trim
I'll cut probably in the middle I'd say
oh nice look at that oh oh it's hot
steamy real see me moment of truth
shall we taste her off my chest bathroom
nice I cracked my cousin John sucking
video she did yeah she did that's my bad
what's hot dinner good it's very crunchy
it's actually really good uh-huh my eyes
are burning because it's burning my
mouth mm-hmm not bad hot it's actually
something I would eat I am eating it I
think it's really good like I I can
honestly how to present tell you that I
did not mess this up I know it's kind of
weird I'm enjoying it
it smells light I gotta get the shoes
fixed look Mike dude is so loose this is
awful thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed this video
if you did make sure you hit the like
button and leave me a comment on what
you would like to see me cook next don't
forget to subscribe so you see the next
video that I might actually not mess up
you believe it can you leave imma leave
it steamy look we're breaking bread
together this is great
I'm just gonna just take this is great
I'll wrap this up and eat it tomorrow
for breakfast food yeah my tooth is
loose I've got I've emergency somebody
called 9-1-1
Shorty's losing her tooth like in the
kitchen this is what happens when my
body feel good really good I'm hungry
it's really good it's a glare I'm hungry
no it's good good what for me
consuella your stop it yeah yeah okay
these are sprinkles I just bought these
yeah